welcome I'm calling with film
independent today it's all about a case
study of one of my favorite movies from
last year we're joined by the filmmaking
team behind the film see you yesterday
with us we have director and co-writer
Stephane Bristol Stefan welcome hello
hello are you doing
well I'm very blessed you know I mean I
live in Brooklyn New York
so the pandemic I hear is crazy and I'm
praying baby body and bombs on alright
and with us two issues co-writer
Fredrika bailey finito welcome hello
hello thank you for having me so excited
to be here with you guys great to have
you both
your film queue yesterday is playing on
Netflix it won the Best Screenplay at
the 2020 Jonathan at Spirit Awards it
was also nominated for Best first
feature so congratulations on being
Spirit Award winners thank you thank you
it was later on but before we start why
don't you just give us your kind of line
[Music]
divided the doors its see yesterday is a
it's about two teenagers from Brooklyn
New York who invented a time travel to
save one their brothers from being
wrongfully killed by a police officer
take us back to the beginning I'm a
sucker for a great time travel movie and
this is a great one it's got I love the
political twist
I like how you folded that into the
story without it being too political no
it was the the thing that drove the mean
the the reason to try and travel but it
fulfilled and you know way too heavily
on it so yeah no it's not I know it you
started writing this as a feature before
you started writing it as a short right
yes yes so when I was at NYU I was tired
of you know
this whole what what kind of films you
should make this arthouse films on my
knob I came into the school you know I
want to be like an action-adventure
filmmaker I had some good good products
that I made him from school that was
good and others that were not great but
I say you know what I'm gonna make a
movie that I want to make our you don't
give a damn about what anybody thinks
so I came up a note in my mind I knew I
want to have black kids and there's
sapphire I don't know what it would be
but there's gonna be that however it was
during during the summer sooo
significant significant things happened
her significant thing is one of my one
of my family members was alcoholic and I
was depressed by that I was going
through something personal with that so
I just you know to help me cope with I
was watching back to the future and
repeat so I just put two ideas together
young young young teen go back a time to
stop his drunken father or grandfather
from killing his best friend who drunk
driving but another thing happened
during that summer is when Eric garner
got murdered by the by the police
officer in San Allen and I also remember
about Mike Brown two previous summer and
the Trayvon Martin trial is also there
so even though I was writing a
completely different story a scene of
police brutality was blend to my script
and there was a feature script so when I
Professor Mon saw the draft it was very
excited about the idea she shoved the
draft she said stuff on you know you
have a scene of police brutality in the
script it's very distracting
there's other one or two things you
could do one you can either take it out
because it's very distracting or to let
that be the story especially with what
was happening in the climate today in
United States I was like yo that's
genius
so I said I'm gonna go with that and so
I did that and I went to my professors
at NYU saying it was a March this time I
had a script it was March and it's my
presence here 20 oh that's good question
2015 okay
um yes 20 no 2014 or 2015 I think was 24
caramel is one of that went to them and
say yo I have a script saying what you
think there's a March I said this is my
feature script I'm a shooting in June
everybody right right everybody said I
was delusional I was like oh okay and
but they say look you don't have any
films in your other short films to
showcase you'll work to finance ears for
you to make a make a feature so a Balu
of you to make a short make a spray
strong short let that be your thesis and
take that short and use it to make a
feature I would like okay all right
whatever you know saying so I said fine
you know I don't have a chance but I'm
glad I'm glad it told me that because
you know long story short could have
short I get to learn a lot more what
means to be a director and a lot more
have to work with actors and especially
I learn my weakness as a writer and my
witnesses I need a co-writer and you
know fast forward I'll talk about how I
got Rodriguez but I want I want to you
know share interesting experience where
I started doing the short I had two
close friends of mine at that time who
are my producers does it work with me
for Flores my producers and I got them
on what to produce the film and a lot of
problems happen with those producers I
mean you know there was a lot of issues
between us we couldn't find the
financing I felt like I was doing most
of the work and it was getting close to
like I was trying to graduate but by the
time you know I needed to shoot two
weeks before production I had to fire
them and pull the plug it up and it was
hard and unfortunately today I'm no
longer talking to them something
brothers and I cried for a week a cry
for a week but I believe in the project
had to go to back to my mom except for
for some money it's a pain rent and my
mother to help me you know keep going
with the project she's refinanced her
home she put up you know thousands of
dollars for the project to get here you
know here's here's two months rent
here's some Duckett's for you to save on
to do that so that gave me the strength
to move to move forward but I believe in
the projects that look my mom Lepus
project I believe in a project but my
writings you know it having the
production failed that's a great now I
could focus more on the ride because of
writing need a lot of work to but I knew
I come in I need help I knew I couldn't
do them all so I went to the chair of
the NYU graduate on Friday Department
and asked them you know I have us have
to have this project is it any of your
students that that matches the criteria
to help me up with this it gave me a
short list and you know fujiko's on that
list and I interviewed I read every one
script and I interviewed everybody
thoroughly yes and and I know who I
needed
patrika was the only black woman on the
list but on top of that oh I should say
I'm wrong with that she was only she was
the best rider up and no lie and I'm
glad I got her because you know me her
you know work together every weekend
during the fall semester just you know
in the library in Brooklyn just you know
chopping getting the script done spike
was able to I gave her the spike
apply for his grants he also introduced
some books for Jake oh and I got the
grant in January and then about April
you know when I have all the money in
funds to finally got together it was
right
so yeah Frederika what was what so you
know evolved in a writing a time travel
to stop a police shooting and Stefan
brings you into some beef up the
characters what would we bring into the
project well I think he had like a draft
of the short but I think it was just
about making sure that everything kind
of gelled together it was a must
I wasn't saying gel together so it was
beating up the characters but also
making sure everything kind of you know
like I said gel together because
remember when you're talking about time
travel then you're talking about a lot
of cause and effect
so also plot wise how are we making sure
things you know make sense are somewhat
logical but then also that the time
travel aspect doesn't overshadow the
issue of police brutality which was very
important about Stefan and I so I think
that's where I kind of came in and kind
of helped to kind of you know breathe
and massage it a little bit and breathe
a little bit more into it as far as just
getting that aspect together and you
know making sure that CJ was was reading
well and Sebastian was reading well and
kind of establishing their relationship
I kind of just help them to massage all
of that stuff together and so it's so
funny because I was you know I was very
excited because I think one of the
things I was hoping for before I met
Stefan was I was like oh it'd be great
if I could meet a director who I you
know really you know got along with and
gelled with and that way you know maybe
I wanted to worry so much about
directing on my own if I can meet
someone that gets me maybe I could form
you know a partnership lifelong
partnership the way a lot of actors and
directors do and I had no idea that
Stefan was around the corner so I'm so
glad that you know he came around
because little bits he know I was
actually wishing for someone like him so
it was just the perfect fit when it kind
of ended up coming together in that way
and said the action-adventure part that
he loves to do which is not necessarily
the biggest genre of interest at NYU
it's definitely not like that at my
dramatic writing department so I feel
like our John Roos connected and I was
the only one that kind of really liked
that we
how's the light you know and so it was
just I think it was meant to be in that
way the short is super lean and
stripped-down
you chose not to really talk about the
time how they figured out the time
travel at all that's you know it starts
right yeah yeah sorry
no she could say yeah you know we only
got those what 15 pages and you're just
trying to like get as much in it's
possible and really established the
character so I think that was why you
didn't get to delve more into how they
created the time travel aspect which is
one of the great things about the
feature because then you got to really
expand that world and get to see a
little bit more of that process and
learn more about them and their
backstory so that was one of the good
things that I loved about the future and
in a do I add you know we only have 15
minutes yeah that's one that's all I can
budget for and that's ten to once you
have that a short film out into
festivals the festival thing about you
know the rule of thumb that's what's not
going to take a short from more than 15
minutes yeah you know which is
unfortunate I which I Percy fine is
ridiculous because there's so many you
know short films that's amazing you know
30 minutes short Cal aging sky has a
beautiful short called Samaria 30
minutes long my nephew Emmett by Kevin
Wilson jr. wow that's a very long movie
for a short film and if one a student
Academy Award but I hardly have heard
anything about in a festival circuit I
think it's ridiculous but I kept it
strategically down there because you
know I want to make sure how people's
attention so before we get on to the
feature you shot this short after
getting the grant from Spike Lee that's
enough so how much did the short cause
look short let me remind the audience as
a filmmaker as a students you got
liberties and you got free equipment
what's actually really be paid for but
you have this access to equipment you'll
have to learn it plus insurance that's
cost from down and labor it's free labor
so that's cost down as well
you know you know I was he blessed
enough to get free location I was
blessed enough to get the actors worked
for free I was you know all that was a
blessing all that would I easily have me
cost me of over 80,000 maybe a hundred
but his film well the photo footage
because of all my luck it was 20 grand
for the short film as a student I got
five guys for my mom 5000 15,000 from
spike grant Spike Lee grant the initial
5,000 but additional 10,000 once he saw
the final cut so he could help me you
know with the sound design and the music
sweaty grant I'm sorry two grand from a
failed from a failed Kickstarter
campaign three grand
from student loans so then I'm gonna go
hole deep in that number the short and
then sure to spike I sort of you know
I've shown the final cut that spike was
busy shoot and she's gotta have it
season 1 that time and when I saw him
when he saw the rough cut I was
expecting him
if anybody knows 5 I was expecting him
to be you know cussing me out like you
know how terrible job I'm doing but you
know if even if they still good job he's
always find a way to school you which is
fine you know I'm saying because you
know I was a young filmmaker in the game
and he wanted you know make sure I was
you know doing things correctly but to
my surprise he was like oh this is good
this is great and you know and giving me
five and pounds and say yeah now you're
Morehouse man and I was like odd [ __ ]
and once he saw the cut he was like yo
you need to do some reshoots and you
need to do some color and make sure the
music is tight I said spike I ain't got
no money what you see is it it was like
nah nah nah nah nah send me a budget
I'll give you the rest and and I was
like wow and then he also knew I was
gonna make this into a feature so months
later you know a couple nights before
Christmas he emails me saying hey until
you making a feature and I don't want
step on anybody's toes
but I would love to be your producer
think about it just think about it let's
go think about it and likely to produce
your feature film yes you know it wasn't
like I take classes with spike and he
knows me it was like I worked for him
Wow you know before I was in film school
and wallows on from school so I met him
at Morehouse got an internship and I did
some jobs with them when I was a student
okay so let's go back to taking the
short and make making it into a feature
and now you have the liberty of you've
got now an extra 15 minutes of screen
time to add to this short
Frederico you can now get really deep
into this sort of yeah with the
complexities of time travel and also
kind of hints of how and I could you
give them a there's a sort of they have
a method here but you don't explain it
too much like so how'd you get that
balance right of the system they're
using without it bogging this the whole
story down yeah well I think like Stefan
and I talked about and that was
something was really important for us
was that we we you know we did a little
bit of research on our own and you know
also added a lead actress is a science
major and so she you know gave us input
as well but I think the goal was to kind
of explain it enough so that it's
understandable so that it feels real but
then not so much so that the audience
becomes so preoccupied with the rules of
time travel that there
able to focus on the issue of police
brutality we always felt like it was
more of a it was a story about police
brutality and that time travel was how
we were entering that subject matter and
telling that story but we didn't want
the the time travel aspect to be
something that took you away from from
that issue so I think we both talked
about making sure we didn't get too
bogged down in rules and technicalities
and you know oftentimes you don't need
all that type of all that type of stuff
as long as your characters are are
seeming competent and they know what
they're talking about and the audience
is willing to take the ride with you and
so I think that was something that we
did a lot too as far as you know we did
a little bit of research a little bit
about theories of time travel even
though of course time travel was not you
know not true but you know there was
some there's some research out there
there's some theories and things like
that so we use some of that incorporated
some of that lingo and vocabulary but I
think it was important that we you know
did just the right amount so that it
didn't become something that
overshadowed the rest of the film lost
time probably and movies is just you
know there's swimming time travel movies
that people you just that's your setup
people accept it right you don't like a
totally new concept so yeah yeah what's
more important is although some
paradoxes of like seeing themselves or
because you can get into a lot holes
their fact we exactly you want it to
avoid that too so did you talk about now
now that you you're gonna make the
feature how do you get from spike
producing it to it being a go project
offer from spike to it being a go
project with a start date it took I have
to go quite a while by a year okay yeah
because we did some we got know some
spike a couple times yes yes yes working
on the on the script before we took it
out
exactly it did probably take about a
year some rewrites more than a few
rewrites before we were like okay now we
feel comfortable and ready to take it
out and was he taking it to finances
were you in meetings with potential
finances yes you were so like
so when spike came on you know we stood
before we even took it out that's what
Jacob said he had to make you know three
bites and to be both comfortable he
fooled me out to LA the jig was already
out in LA
by the time but actually before you
coming out to LA he let me set me down
set stuff on this is gonna be a studio
movie I was like what that's unheard of
I was not expecting you know this to be
him I would expect him to make this a
very much a real independent film ways
to use this name to raise the funds on
my own but spike when he put his foot
you know put his foot in it he flew me
out often to a lay and we had several
meetings with different production
companies and there were there are some
companies that were great companies that
weren't got a lot of great notes and
then we ended up meeting an executive at
Netflix who was really interested in
doing them film but we haven't heard
from him you know for a while so spike
decided to stop you know pitching and
because he was doing black clansmen and
he invited me to be one of his
assistants but black clansmen where I
get to learn like a real you know how
real Hollywood set looks like and then
by Christmas of 2017 when once the
production is over
he's got me to my 240 acres a Stefan I
got you to deal with Netflix so I was
like what how was that yeah so you ever
jacob better start tighten up the script
and back out to a netflix and you know
we met in particular we met really
really awesome to executives there and
they were amazing and gray and they gave
amazing notes that actually helps the
script could be a lot better yeah
because I was script at that time I
still was very lean very very lean it
was like only 90 pages and we want to
keep it there but it's say you could do
a lot more and it came out to be 110 you
know and then after afterwards we just
for the next six months we could seen
the work of the script until until this
production time yeah you also kept a lot
of similarities with the short they're
you know they're they're sort of
tinkering in their garage and
time-travel takes place and what this be
the same alleyway right there's a lot of
similarities I like the fact you didn't
just suddenly try and make it all
big-budget and lose the charm and sense
of place that the short had yeah
something you know I want I want it I
want to know I wanted to keep that
because I knew it's an independent film
I knew you know what we were trying to
do but at the same time I wasn't trying
to make it like back to the future or
Jurassic Park or something like that
like I don't have the skill set for that
yet and so it was like okay I wanted to
make a movie about you know young black
kids in the hood who are much different
than we ever seen before and that takes
a personal story very quiet you know
very very controlled a very contained
and and and and tell stories that told
their story in a very specific point of
view because in my in my opinion a good
film is very specific because they're
very specific and personal you are the
more universal it is a little bit about
the cost you had any Duncan Smith and
Dante in your short deep wanted to keep
them in the future
oh we had the final is never that first
necklace in a wanna you had the final
you know it's fibers like not being
having them it's all was like it made no
sense look like you know it's
understandable because I was a
first-time filmmaker I had a first-time
so director photography to Jake his
first time you know nothing of my anyone
have first time you were also want names
to really bring into audience I was like
you know look was this understandable I
was like usually you know but this is
but that's not to come I want to make
it's like the audience gonna find the
film and they have thankfully and I've
you know discuss a little later but it's
like if you you know you know it's nice
to have fresh faces and for the audience
to grow with somebody Dante Eden and
Dante they're great and you know they're
best friends in real life and and they
did a great job in the short why do we
have to fix you know fix something
that's not broken you know do they often
me like hey you want to know check out
song so I was like now I know who I want
and and I love them both
you know Edinborough loves them both to
their you guys yeah yeah they were fun
to work with it was very fun to work
with and both of them have helped me
develop the script with the chicken on
it in a way even onset as I go stuff on
this there's a flaw right I'm not I
don't feel like you know this character
would do this mine I was like you know
do you think what's up no Eddin help us
was a lot with the science she is in
Hampton University studying physics and
she has a work work study with NASA Wow
okay so that brilliant my little more
sense there because they were totally
convincing as I totally believed that
they would know everything of what it
takes to to create a time machine out of
a man and it was on our assets about it
- yeah so how long's your shoot then I
mean that obviously winner you win your
fight with Netflix over your cast how
many days do you shoot
what do you shoot on you answer those
two we shot well
go back a little bit four weeks off prep
six week hard prep five weeks
twenty-five days of shooting remember
eight to nine months of post
it's like birthing a child during that
per Don that post oh my god if you want
to if you want to test your patience as
a director post production is it some
people love that and it's you know in a
one-room and you know like kind of a
nine-to-five yeah you know you know
working all that way you can work for me
it was like it was I'm not complaining
it wasn't for me it was like it was my
first time experiencing post production
because I wasn't able to see what spike
did in pop and black clansmen so suppose
I see what he did for for shooting so I
couldn't you know already I was there
every day so I already had the muscle
but it had any muscle for post
production so everything it was like
brand-new for me and I heard sometimes
post-reduction can go over a year and a
half yeah so you know I don't know I
loved every process of it and had an
amazing freakin editor Jennifer Lee if
you know she helped us rewrite the
script in post there was Lee know we she
saw so many flaws even during production
the gun will be shooting she will call
me up and say yo you got to get this
shot I think you need to make changes to
the script here you know the
performances need a believable at this
point so I'm a match for this
performance as you already have over
here that's not so working so you know
during post we had like a lease well how
many how many a screen screen test like
six so many yeah but they were super
healthy you was screening in front of
audiences
yeah privately like we only invited
friends and friends of friends that have
no idea about the short that's very
important so he won't be tainted and
also who are not just directors but you
know other people in the industry or
storytellers that we fight a lot of
comic book artists there for the private
screenings
comic writers other writers other
editors which is also extremely helpful
and and Jennifer should be in front of
the of the audience and she will be
she'll be monitoring the Q&A because as
you told me be in the back and don't
talk such amount and you know the first
time I slipped in that's trying to talk
and everything but I could see why you
know even though hearing the feedback me
cringe a lot I heard you know she was
able to get all the information she
needs you know so we know what what is
honest and not and no one's gonna be
swayed because of Directors in the room
that's very important you don't want
nobody to be sway because the directors
in the room you know you know I had to
sit in the back be quiet so everyone
could be complete honest if anyone have
any frustration
it will all be you know on her and I
thought that was brilliant yeah I mean
they say you shouldn't really scream for
your friends because your friends won't
be honest
exactly screenings with friends friends
who scream for family and it's wonderful
wonderful know what no one is offers any
criticism at all not these friends they
will they will let me know yeah yeah you
need to be about it like slightly here
as can narrow down and pinpoint the
problem tell you right exactly I mean as
funny as the sound is now funny but you
because you really need because you know
iron steel sharpens steel I shot my eye
on you you need people to be brutally
honest no matter how how hurtful it is
you know it might it might be wrong but
you but you need newly honestly just to
make sure your work is legit a little
bit about kind of the mental preparation
it takes two takes to go from having
made to shorts to like oh my god I'm
shooting this 25 days shoot for Netflix
okay this is important I've got to get
it right
baby how do you keep grounded and how do
you prepare for that and are there gaps
in your knowledge you need to film
before you step on set
I I was a bit cocky I'm not gonna lie
cuz I was like this is just the day I've
been waiting for this [ __ ] you know
saying I was like yeah let's do it
but it's not until I was on set honestly
maybe the second week we had a whole
bunch of problems that we had some was
someone's my fault half a half that
other was like weather and and and and
what have you
what really
sometimes stifled me a little bit you
know maybe sometimes leading up to it on
seven even even in post-production well
you said that when you see the first cut
who I feel like jumping off the Brooklyn
Bridge is that you have a school apps
trinomial amount of money for your first
feature film was unheard of so you know
II have executives and you have a whole
team and a whole bunch of other people
rely on you because you're supposed to
know your vision and you and you have to
prove himself um when that was short I
didn't give a [ __ ] like anybody think I
just want to make sure the story is told
correctly anyone understands what's
happening you understand what's
happening why don't you understand
I don't give a damn I don't give a [ __ ]
if you like it enough here I'm like [ __ ]
tetriminos is gone but his movie I
really care if he's gonna give a [ __ ]
you know I'm saying I really care you
like this give you gonna like it or not
and you gotta get because it's like it's
not just the one or two executives I was
working with you as other executives at
Netflix is gonna watch your film and you
even get noticing and get feedback and
then you got and it's just like it was
it was challenging to you know I'm you
know filmic is very it's a very humbling
experience and I was extremely humble
about it because it really took a jab a
GE go so many times
frederica were you one set every day I
was I was which was great thanks to step
on I was there every day I was based out
here in LA at the time but the night you
know flew out it was over the summer so
I flew up to New York and stayed out
there and got the chance to be there
every day which was great as a writer
because we know that's not always our
experience
and so I got to learn like so much about
just seeing the filming and production
all that I could stuff so yeah that was
awesome there was any rewrites during
production
there were yeah there were a couple of
times where we had to like you know step
in and add a little bit more dialogue
for characters I know the funeral scene
we had to add dialogue for the for the
pastor during the funeral scene so that
was written while on set and there was a
couple of instances yet which was also
again like a good experience for me I
didn't realize that you know just going
from school to being on set you don't
realize like some of the different ways
that you still are constantly rewriting
even you know actually writing while on
set so that was a really good muscle for
me to kind of work fine I think this
life changed when we did reach the
cherry pages I think it was a lot yeah
maybe past sure um it also location a
lot of lean a lot we do location scouts
and a lot of locations made us you know
change on the script especially like the
special last-minute last-minute location
changes yeah and our request I need it
for drink I could I I couldn't you know
I couldn't make those changes a mom
[Music]
excited and glad to be there I'm gonna
get to some questions in a minute so
people listening in feel free to type
your questions in there using the Q&A
button at the bottom see before that
let's get to the sort of release of the
film you are in a very lucky position to
take you know like a this scrap the
indie movie you have to take around the
festival circuit and hope someone is
interested enough to buy it and a
bidding war you have Netflix taking us
out into the world from the get-go so
you know we were you involved in any of
that sort of
marketing decisions yes I was you know
nothing that day that's what I love
working with Netflix know how to work
with them again predict it wasn't a room
one of the marketing meetings yeah with
you yeah they allowed us to pick also a
pic but they allow us to give meaningful
consultation to the poster I'll let them
happen like there was some throw some
trash posters I'm gonna lie to you I'm
have it but you know the post I'll be
there was some really amazing posters as
well yeah they invite us in the
marketing meeting they'll let they
actually let us know is one of my
biggest concerns was make sure that the
hood knows about this from I want to
make sure that young black teens know
about this movie and it's like how you
how you prepare you know plan for that
and they let me know most of social
media
I said look we've got to get black
journalists on this you know post the
route okay play okay Africa like I
wanted all that and if they mean you
know they made sure you know they're
included you know community screenings
as well I flew out you know to LA and
and to Atlanta for the community
screenings and and those screenings I'm
hearing you know kids say yo that's my
own cool yo that's my block that's how
we talk you know I'm saying and now that
that brought joy to my heart and I'm
gonna make sure that happened but the
biggest surprise a thing about the
marketing meeting like you know I was
almost floored they showed that our
movie was gonna was gonna be showcased
on billboards oh yeah sue in LA yeah
[ __ ] Times Square like if I die
tomorrow you know I'll be happy I'd be
having like this battle knowing like you
made it to Times Square already yeah
whose decision was it to sort of release
the film given a Tribeca premiere
uh it was it was I was I pushed for it
was my decision I pushed for them I said
look you know just you know I cuz I'm
very competitive I want to make sure
that people know about the film as much
as possible we got some good reviews and
so I said let's do it the Tribeca
because we know critics gonna beat it
so I pushed them in you know we sent him
late in the game to Tribeca but they you
know thankfully you know they loved to
film and I got my you know but you can
now you got family out there on the red
carpet starting but we doesn't but it
was very important for Becca because you
know we want to make sure that that's a
great marketing tool for the film and to
get the word idea as much as possible I
do this this movie's gonna come up and I
was you know doing my n on social media
and emails I made sure we all I think
anyone made sure that there's a line
down the block yeah the screens went
really well really well did Netflix
change the release date to coincide with
Tribeca and have it come out right after
the festival honestly I cannot remember
you know honestly I think it was a while
for them to get the release day because
they blues waiting for Tribeca drop key
week softer tribe that Tribeca screen
yes the top two weeks yeah because like
you know I wanted to keep less quick
anticipation look at the world idealist
great participation and wants to drop
you know people will like oh I keep
hearing about this film
finally is on let's go so that's just
typically that you know we should think
we did that
so I questioned further sort of audience
response and reaction like when
something is on Netflix and it doesn't
go to theaters you don't see people in
line you know you can't feed the
box-office takings every weekend you
know the zero average is you know it's
on Netflix it's probably being seen by a
lot of people but engaged the response
as a film open to see how people
reacting to your work will you you like
listening tweets what
so yeah so I I'm not big on social media
but that is how I would gauge the
response and Stefan to engage the
responsible social media as well I would
tell him not read everything that ever
almost costs people out system or
reading everything that he would call me
be like this is what someone said I'm
like why are you reading all of this so
but that was a good way to engage like I
didn't read every treatment purpose but
what I was thinking he's guessing that
was that people were seeing the movie
and it was starting conversation
especially with the ending the ending
seemed to spark a lot of conversation so
that's how I kind of gauged to me that
it was doing well so like people are
talking about it that was reading every
tweet like Stefan I told him every other
minute did you see that no I did not
because I'm not reading all of that I
cuz I cuz people out and I don't believe
the tweets I was a mess because like
y'all like people like people know
that's why I'm like you know next film I
progress cell phones get off social
media I'm also social media right now I
don't have no Facebook or Instagram I
still have Twitter but it's probably I
only go there to check about updates on
coronavirus but you know people like
people be out of pocket saying you know
oh these riders are lazy they don't know
how to complete a movie you know what
the [ __ ] was up with the ending I was
like oh my lord you know so I had a like
a whole bunch of bottles about just the
ending like I woke up 6 o'clock that day
when I released 6 o'clock a.m. see let
me see if same I watched it yo that
emims jacked up what the [ __ ] is wrong
with the ending yo I was like God Jesus
Christ so that hold that the first I'm
not allowed you're the first day I was
really I was I was little I was a little
upset I was just going around supposed
be happy day right that's any filming
people's be happy but I was pissed off
but it was a learning lesson and and
forces
- oh not to what my what the message is
for the film you know I'm saying what
you know I mean by everybody knew I know
Fujiko know Spike Netflix my editor
we all have fights about the ending but
we all understood what it was about and
I'm pitched for that vision and I'm
gonna stick to it and yeah everyone get
it you know I I come out come out of
movies with friends and like people
didn't get the ending and you have to
explain it to them what I do now is get
on social media and tweet about it I
noticed a lot of videos on YouTube
explaining the ending it's like for
those people right yes there are those
well there's one video said you know
this this movie doesn't have an ending
there's no third act I was like and I
almost cut him out that's again mistaken
sir but there's other videos that
actually you know talked about like you
know this is what the ending means is of
the film that was probably going for and
I was like that's it because with the
whole idea for the ending of the film
what's the spark conversation that's one
and for those who said I didn't have
closure that's the whole point
j-bot smarten my mother didn't have
closure the wife of Eragon I didn't have
closure you know I'm saying you know the
girlfriend of flame of Castile she don't
have any closure that's one of the
reason why and it that way and he could
be doing this a lot more times exactly
ten minutes after your film ended for a
long time exactly and it's in this up
and you know I don't want to drag this
out but these are the reasons - just
before we go to questions little wanna
say a little bit about the sprue wards
you got two nominations for Best first
feature Best first screenplay how was
your experience that you won Best first
screenplay
it was amazing right like it was you
know pinch myself
timing was everything so I remember my
mom came out cuz I live here in LA so
she flew out and we weren't hearing that
much about the coronavirus and all that
other stuff and sometimes everything
that's happened now I get that that was
you know almost feels like 2020 going on
forever
I forget that oh yeah ceremony happened
this is all on the same here only a
matter of months ago because so
craziness has happened since then but
and I'm stuck over here in LA and my mom
is in Maryland but one of the things
that her and I often talked about was
how we at least had had opportunity to
have that special moment together at the
awards with her as my plus-one and you
know doing everything with her and
hanging out with Stefan and his mom and
having her at the dinner and spike was
there and just haven't been able to have
that fun time together um it was just
amazing and you know the shock of when
they called our name and going up there
which I don't remember any I don't
remember even walking up there I don't
remember what I said I'm freaking out
because I was like oh I was supposed to
write something and I left it at the
hotel and I was like I guess I winged
get how that's gonna go you know it was
just a lot but I'm glad I didn't
remember any of it I'm glad I didn't
scare too hard as the audience because
after I got off I was like oh my god I
think Jennifer Lopez was out there what
if I admit I contact with her thank God
I didn't see any faces but my bike that
was it only faces I saw so I was like
okay good good that might would shoot me
up if I were looked out there like oh my
god I'm taking Spencer and she's looking
at me you know so but that was awesome
it was so great to have that moment we
were so like humbled and grateful you
know I couldn't have asked for anything
more than to be up there to be up there
with Stefan you know has invited me on
this pre-greek journey like when they
call your name that hot that hole see
yesterday table display I was like I was
not you know I was me ah she goes you
know I was like me personally I can't be
saying when I was I was expecting that
to win you know I'm saying I was like oh
you know everyone is gonna you know get
the wards I was just there for my mom
but my mom
mom just to have half our son both like
though this prestigious event you know
and I want my mom to experience that you
know geez you know I think both of our
parents come from humble beginnings it's
like you know we're not used to someone
if I used something like this you know
walking a red carpet what's blue but we
still call it red
welcome to red carpet being around so
many celebrities like you know that's
something we see on TV once a year and
that's the Oscars that's it um so I was
there sitting down getting in my wine
spot with me enjoy I said damn random
will be enjoying this and I was like I
was planning to get drunk and I had once
they were saying the names of the
nominees I was drinking and I was like
half goat when they announced to work
nuts that we want I almost told them
myself
I can't remember anything else I blacked
out after that we better get used to
like hanging out on the red carpet and
it's not gonna be your first time
it's not gonna be your last time I read
your lips to God's ears yeah I'm doing
this because I love to work yeah so got
some questions here Wendy says hi I
really like the movie the script was
tight but where I think you really
excelled was in casting every role large
and small this was cast well I love the
characters and didn't want the story to
end how do you approach casting question
about the casting director and how long
was the casting process the classic
process the way I approached casting is
I just had to make sure that you kept
that whoever we cast this authentic to
for the character not that I'm trying to
pigeonhole certain someone in it by just
might make sure they'd be authentic for
that character that I believe them for
example will be casting the hardest
outside of Ed in and Dante's roles the
other hardest was asked the brother
Astro and then the mutt with the mother
who was played by Marsha Stephanie Blake
great great actress great freaking
actress okay you know I hope to work
with her again ask you know there were
folks I needed people who exudes
Brooklyn so the team someone that had a
little edge on them but your sweethearts
honest in the same way you know I'm
saying if you just like to be from Ruby
there's a certain for a brought out a
certain way you walk a certain way you
talk and I need somebody friendly
especially like that
so my casting directors they did a good
job bringing these people but I brought
some brought in one stroke a Amen I know
he was it hands down and Marcia her role
like nothing no Netflix and wanted you
know somebody you know who's more famous
with whatever also helps sell the film
once again understandable she came in
and and she know the material right away
and and she was just perfect for it
somebody else said a question about how
Michael J Fox wrote attached Oh question
that that was a happy accident as well
because we was he was gunning for we
know we had a cameo role he doesn't know
who's gonna play it but I said know it
get my man Neil deGrasse Tyson honest
oh but unfortunately was unavailable so
it was like okay who else I was making a
list
I had Christopher Lloyd and then
obviously Bill Nye the Science Guy then
one of my Jason Sokolov my executive
producer he was LARP adducing to film he
said why not we just go for the Michael
J Fox I'm sorry can we get on like
that's legend like I don't know you know
we'll see
so we all you know I start writing a
letter and do one helped pitch in to
make sure that the letter is tight and
essentially in that letter a toll as
singing them as a thoughts if you do
this film your presence in the film will
help sell the messages of the movie
they'll be trying to say you know and
also you plan a teacher will help
saw the message that you know for these
you know really top schools in NYC they
need to pay it more attention of
bringing in young black in black and
brown kids and then you know we came on
set at first we couldn't get him on set
because there was an accident so we had
every schedule so when he came on set
ready to go super like super strike star
superstar and you know I'll pinch myself
and so many times like there was a time
I forgot to say action because I was so
giddy that you not gonna take shots and
during between setups I said he'll you
know how what do you think of the
scratch Michael told me sorry mr. Fox
told me I didn't read the script but
this did it off your letter Wow the good
letter it was a touching moving good
letter all of us how long's our letter
to like the Jayhawks it was just it was
just one-page letter okay you know we
had to change the font to make it fit
though you know no warm it's times to
Malia has a question for you both what
advice would you give to up-and-coming
no deal in their representation
filmmakers of color who are committed to
telling our narratives well I mean I
think that I think the best advice that
I could give is to you know tell tell
your story I would say you know don't
worry about necessarily what you think
where the market is going or trying to
anticipate the market or trying to just
focus so much on that but I think
focusing more on telling the stories
that you tell the best that are specific
to you and your experience that are
authentic to you that touch you that
moves you and telling those in a very
concise and you know type thorough way
will be the things that will get you the
the notoriety that you need to attract
the attention of a manager
or an agent or you know things like that
I think they kind of I used to hear this
all the time especially at school they
would say oh they'll find you and I kind
of didn't quite get it but that is sort
of how it happens once you start you
know doing good work and you have like a
lot of good samples had lots of samples
if you're a writer director or whatever
it is have plenty of samples but once
you start doing that and you have really
quality samples they will find you and
what they'll do is ask to read or see
whatever it is you've done and it may
not be that first sample so I know with
my manager I sent him maybe six or seven
features that I had focused on while at
school and it was the last one that made
him say oh yeah yeah yeah let's let's
work together so I would just say be
really prepared work on your craft and
have a lot of samples and just kind of
focus on that and then you will get
eventually get the attention that you're
looking for and that way your
preparation will be there to meet the
opportunity when it comes
stefan same thing with the jika said you
know we need so young people color we
need honest personal original stories
you know don't don't try to figure out
what the network wants don't try to
figure out what the studio wants it has
to be absolutely personal and new and
refreshing because got to remember black
people are not a model at the group
we're not a model at the monolithic
group we got black Jamaicans we got
American black people from Florida we
got afro-brazilians so if you have
something that's very specific and
culturally specific and culturally
honest there's going to be very
universal believe you me and if anybody
want to challenge you on you know why
you need to do this film or or you know
can you brought it [ __ ] them
mmm you need to tell your personal story
make sure you stuff this person excuse
my language undercuts a lot today but I
have to be honest because I want I want
people to be successful but also
remember reading that you saying that
you kind of found your voice when you
realize
the movies that you loved growing up on
were kind of the genre you should be
working in science fiction action stuff
yeah I could take some more social
stories it's I want to mesh them
together yeah you know I hope people
find they see yesterday's like that I'm
I'm influenced by two filmmakers Spike
Lee and Steven Spielberg you know I love
Jurassic Park and I love do the right
thing you know how can I miss those kind
of tones together and also bring my own
press experience as you know a person of
image from an immigrant family how can I
do something like that so it's a lot of
trial and error but you know I found my
voice and you know by doing the short
film it's like this is this is it you
know I always been discouraged from
doing all the action stuff and do more
artsy fartsy independent film and I'm
pay you know I'm not knocking it I'm not
not good at all but it wasn't my voice
was it for me I know exactly what I
wanted to do and and I had to say [ __ ]
it I'm gonna do what my mind sees and
work my ass off to make sure that it you
know from the concept of writing it's a
lot of trial and error I don't make sure
every step of the way if you understand
what's happening I don't give a damn if
you like last question here from me doze
says do you think development would have
turned out differently if the film had
been a straight-up personal drama rather
than a film that expresses those layers
through a Jorah I guess he means without
the time-travel aspect to it
we're tired of seeing that films we
really have a lot of police fatality
films a lot of you know in the hood
violence yeah yeah but that's called
boys in the hood mini society strap
fresh what else and those are all
amazing movies and then I'm not knocking
them yeah yeah yeah I just I just I
didn't I didn't want to make that again
it is already been made you know I'm not
knocking them like you know boys in the
hood a menace to society man you know
our you know our r.i.p John Singleton
but I did and I need to find my voice
so we're almost out of time we usually
end these QAS with questions for
everyone one what are you watching can
you recommend like what the makers of
see you yesterday what would you say
people should be watching while they're
stuck in at home it can be an old
classic hidden gem something new just
feel to dig deep as you like mm maybe
your favorite time-travel movies again
let's see I recently binge tween so no
on Netflix which I really really liked
about a South African basically spy and
it's a series and it's about her you
know being a badass black woman who's a
spy so I actually really enjoyed that I
recently finished black is enjoy that
what else and then like some oh and I
recently just yesterday I watched the
sci-fi movie I think it's called 30 22
with Omar X that's on that place and
that was pretty pretty good as well I
enjoyed that yeah and I'm just like yeah
I think those are the main things I
caught up on some things that I just
totally missed like Mad Men I totally
missed that boat and just catching up
something on some of those old class did
you miss that boat too yeah never got
around to it oh you should yeah get one
she's art it'll just consume you that in
the water yes I miss wire boat as well
I'm gonna get on that at some point but
yeah so that and I also started watching
once upon a time which I really liked
you know who knew but yeah so those are
the things that I've done thus far will
see and because you're writing a lot
right you know I
I'm trying but I'm also trying to be
kind to myself and the fact that I have
to you know I feel like I had a lot to
do but I have to remind myself that I'm
not at home because there's a retreat
you know I'm at home because there's a
pandemic there's some anxiety for me
around that you know my mom is in
Maryland she's still working we're just
concerning for me I'm you know
quarantine alone so I'm trying to write
but then I'm also making sure that I
remember not to put too much pressure on
myself because for me the priority right
now is my mental health and if that
aligns with writing then I'm gonna write
and when it doesn't align with writing
then then I'm not going to because I
have to just you know I have to get
through this and then I have to UM you
know figure out what's next and you know
how do I get to my mom
most importantly though yeah any pics
from you man I've been trying to catch
up on the classics you know I've been
watching I'm how a face in the crowd
sweet smell of success
what's one of my favorites oh because
I'm working on another film right now
just close the deal another film I'm so
I'm you know watching films I help
pertain to that film that film film that
helps me a lot right now is the Battle
of Algiers good good good good good
I you can't tell if it's a drama or a
documentary it just shreds that line so
well yeah it does and it's and it's very
honest because it shows the wrong of
both sides and you know it just reminds
you like you know colonialism was enough
long ago yeah yeah it wasn't that one of
them yeah the Bona wanted a big with you
is IO and it you said to your favorite
movies are Jurassic Park and back to the
future don't judge
there's like fantastic movies though so
like everyone should aspire to make big
crowd-pleasing pop for movies like that
they're not I wouldn't be embarrassed to
love those I'm not I'm not barest I'm
not that much I don't judge but as I
don't judge me on this stuff I'm not
embarrassed by it I just know I guess I
mean a lot of filmmakers and and other
people who'd not don't understand it
like we are because we know where we
know we became from but there's a lot of
people that when I say that's I really
like that you like those oh my god have
you not seen see Jurassic Park like I
don't understand like you know I'm
saying like I just made a lot of
people's you'd be surprised I mean a lot
of people does not not into it so I put
up there as a safety like love I will
cut you if you make fun of my love's oh
my gosh he's so extreme I had one more
question about the short which is it is
it anywhere that people can see it
streaming the question now is not
currently not know it finished it's
finished on HBO back just past February
so I'm not sure again later however you
know because I'm so busy with everything
that's a good question I mean I haven't
really shopped it around or you know
because I know you know it'll be nice to
get it out there I don't know that's not
my priority right now but you know I
could we won't have to share the link if
any might want to figure that out okay
if anyone is interested they can you
know educate you know defendant donald
and what are you working on now
meliha he smells like that he wants me
to go um
so Stefan and I we were starter we're
working on our next idea we're trying to
hash that out and break that out and
then we start have another thing that
we're working on that's you know sort of
moving along so there's two things that
we've kind of
working on together they're both
features but I don't go into detail on
either one so go do that
I can't you did you can't I can because
I'm not gonna give much details to it
because you know but I did a jig and I
are personally working on is an alien
invasion movie in the veins of African
history and mythology okay very broad so
we can't we can't do much but if at
least take something hopefully if it
sparked your interest and the other film
that be working on and particular came
in to help the writing is really really
really strong rewrite uh-huh as a black
Indiana Jones film set in Ethiopia in
1928 and we're you know we're right now
we put that out to to some studios and
hopefully you hear back from people here
and it is like I have never seen this
movie before and I've never seen a movie
like to see you yesterday before like
mesh meshing those two like the social
and the sci-fi genre together and don't
wait to see them
thank you thank you thank you both thank
you Frederico for being here thank you
for having me thank you thank you for
having us yeah thank you so much that
means a lot
yeah so you I hope you both stay safe
healthy insane and come back to talk to
us very soon about your next project out
there in the world well you guys do
everyone be safe it'll be a couple of
years okay thank you
you
[Music]